more than how many good girls are there
we're not facing that much that's why it
shouldn't be mandatory yeah
it would add to the problem if it was
mandatory I think I don't understand how
you can explain that to me because then
females would not take precaution in who
they sleep with in in terms of it would
it wouldn't really matter because then
their DNA tests will actually tell them
who the father is why why would they be
less they would be less cautious because
there's a DNA test at Birth yeah because
it's mandatory so it doesn't matter who
the father is it will just tell them who
the father is and that'll be it they can
sleep with multiple guys at the same
time do you think women are cautious now
to a degree you just said that there's
no good girl or there's very few good
girls